mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
consolider notre modèle de protection
sociale c'est aussi prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour assurer sa pérennité en
matière de retraite
la crise nous invite plus que jamais à
poursuivre nos objectifs faire un
système plus juste et plus équitable
notamment pour les femmes et pour les
travailleurs modestes passant par la
création d'un régime universel
je les dis et je le répète cela implique
clairement à mes yeux la disparition à
terme des régimes spéciaux tout en
prenant comme nous avions commencé de le
faire dans la réforme de 2008 tout en
prenant pleinement en considération la
situation des bénéficiaires actuels de
ces régimes je suis donc déterminé à ce
que cette réforme parce que c'est
l'intérêt du pays aille à son terme
d'ici la fin de cette législature
mais je pense dans le même temps que
nous devons entendre les inquiétudes et
les incompréhensions qui se sont exprimé
chez nos concitoyens
s'agissant de certaines des modalités du
projet dont le parlement a été saisie je
proposerai donc aux partenaires sociaux
comme aux parlementaires que sur les
bases que je viens d'indiquer la
concertation reprennent rapidement afin
d'améliorer le contenu comme la
lisibilité de cette réforme nécessaire
en la distinguant très clairement de
tout enjeu d'ajustement paramétrique
pour employer des formules
technocratique des régimes existants
je suis en effet convaincu qu'une telle
réforme qui nous engagera pour des
décennies nécessite de prendre le temps
nécessaire
pour essayer de trouver les meilleurs
point d'équilibré
en ce sens elle s'inscrit pour moi
dans la première phase de réforme des
régimes spéciaux décidé en 2007
[Musique]